right now we turn to the phone lines and
welcome back to the rich eisen show from
the tampa bay buccaneers
getting set to tote the rock in the
superdome
leonard fournette how are you leonard
i'm good how are you doing i am doing
fine what a huge game this is this week
leonard what's it like in your
locker room in your world right now for
this one uh
right now you know what i mean we're
just getting ready for uh we just want
to be a dog fight
you know uh you know they have chemistry
they've been playing with each other for
a while
so uh don't be interesting you know we
gotta come in
uh do our job our assignments and just
have faith in our game plan
what's it like having a front row seat
for brady and a big week like this
what's it like walk me through it oh i'm
confident
i know it's tom brady confident enough
you know he's been in these type of
games before he's been in these
situations multiple times
uh a guy like myself and a couple other
guys on offense you know we all been to
playoff games
and we know how how easy it is
to get our past so you know just the
mental things
the small things just staying focused
and mind clear you know uh
and just get into it well i know
definitely you have uh been there uh
before in the playoffs you've had huge
games like say
uh in heinz field by one and dunning the
pittsburgh steelers
um and also you've been in uh a
championship game
against tom brady uh the reason why i
just bring it up is just
have you seen a difference in brady i
guess would be the way to ask it
uh based on what you saw over the first
17 weeks of the season
or uh a handful the the lion's share of
the season where you were there
uh to the last couple weeks leonard have
you noticed a difference
i think i think it's the same you know
he's always had that laser focus
he knows how important each and every
game is
as as always but i think it's just
different
for me being his teammate now and just
seeing
how confident he is back there
even when we're down or we're in tough
situations you know he doesn't lose this
poise
he's he remains the same you know and uh
that's what i love about them and that's
what i love about being back there with
them helping them and protecting them
so how has things uh turned around since
you're by
leonard i mean it's it it looks
different obviously the results are
clearly different
and um the the consistency
is far more uh efficient to say the
least
what happened what happened here do you
think
uh i mean something i can't really uh
answer you know i mean but just know
like uh things happen for a reason
you know i could say that and my job is
to always be ready stay ready
and that's that's what that's that's the
mentality here you know one mile down
next man's up
so just coming in you know understanding
the playbook
100 fully and being confident in my work
and also don't have any doubts when i
touch the field
and just knowing what's that task you
know i mean we have we have a great team
here
great players i understand we can win
and we just
we just have to put the things together
that's about it well i guess i was
meaning as a team leonard obviously i
know you individually
there was a couple weeks where you
didn't see the field and then you
you got in and uh became
uh a very important part of this team in
a manner that we hadn't seen i guess in
the previous weeks
i just i guess i mean offensively as a
whole where things were working and you
could easily say hey you know i'm
playing
that's fine too that's what i was just
wondering here
you know i think i think chemistry it
takes time you know i mean uh
like i said last week was our first
playoff game together you know the
saints
they've been they've been with each
other for some years now and they
understand
and they have a chemistry and i think
we're we're finally getting to their
game today right now a bit by bit we're
not fully there
but it's coming together as you can see
from the last couple of games
and we just have to stay full straddle
gotta
fed him to the middle man i'm not gonna
lie to you you know it's different
and we're ready i can say that we're
gonna be ready
it takes time you know uh it's gonna be
it's gonna be a big one for us
it's gonna be one look leonard obviously
you've got um
a lot of nfl road ahead of you and
you've already
had some extreme success in this league
right you've you've
been there and done that but this is
gonna be something you tell your family
members about
this game i mean we will never see a
game where again
um the quarterbacks are going to come in
with the resumes that these two are
coming in
this is this is this is it you know yeah
you're right about that uh two great
quarterbacks
uh two hall of famers when they retire
uh they have the resume uh just
how they how they've carried themselves
through their careers
you know it's tremendous and to be on
the stage to play with those two guys
uh for a young guy like me is uh no
better feeling
regardless and try to perform just as
better as them or
up the part with them by doing my job
what about leonard fournette here on the
rich eyes and show a few minutes left
with the tampa bay buccaneer running
back
uh in the the previous game um you had
seven touches just one rush
i mean obviously the the scoreboard had
a lot to do with that
but what what are you gleaning from that
loss um
on your home turf against this team
going in like what what have you taken
out of that and that you've seen on film
and you're
you're using for this week anything or
you buried that back in the day
what do you got you got to bury it but
you know some some way somehow it's
still back in mind you know they
embarrassed us
on national national tv you know uh
and as an athlete as a competitor you
know uh it kind of stings
you know you wish you could have done a
lot of things better than what you did
but
right now it's on to the next you know
we moved on from that but we just we
just know that feeling that they gave us
that
at the end of that game and how we felt
so
we're just not trying to feel that no
more to be honest and you must feel
fresh right
is this as fresh as you've ever felt for
a playoff run yeah
yeah it is uh usually around this time
i'll probably have
300 something carries right right now
i'm not like
right now i'm at like 101 so i feel way
better
than i usually did
you've got to feel really i mean this is
this is it i'm i'm i'm jumping out of my
skin i can only matter what what you
must be feeling like
uh going into this one if you don't mind
especially since
you are going back to the state
uh of louisiana leonard i'll just give
you the floor and what this all means
i'm excited you know what being from new
orleans uh playing at lsu
you know uh i know for a fact everyone's
down there as a new orleans fan
i don't know all the saints trying to uh
it's like
it's like it's it's kind of putting
everybody in the in the mix because they
want to they want a group for me but
they root for this thing also
yeah i mean so uh it's exciting exciting
to be back home
play play at my home and uh just ready
to go out and represent the show off
so are you are you um in advance telling
members of your
friends and family uh team fournette um
sorry in advance
are you telling them that in advance no
no no no i'm just i'm just letting them
know i don't want the negative vibes
yeah turn the phone off right you're
turning your phone off right that's for
sure oh yeah
definitely definitely they know do not
call my phone talking about
this thing i'm talking about football
we're gonna talk about like
how life going i don't know about
football because i know deep down they
root for me but they're going for the
same stupid
like uh i i have my friend named pekkas
he says he always says this
i wish i wish the best food he's a new
york giants fan he wish he said
i wish he rushed for 200 yards to lose
by one point against the giants
you know that almost happened actually
you know that was
that was a tight one part of the whole
season here but i love that definitely
you know so you get so you could tell
your friends and family you know who dad
is
but uh don't call be quiet that's
amazing man
this is it well look uh leonard i am
genuinely fired up for this one like
i have already let everybody uh know
that my phone's gonna be off for this
one too
like this is this is it like there's
there's a specific reason why
this game was saved for the final game
of the weekend like
it i i obviously obviously
the uh the the attention from the
quarterbacks merits it but this is also
a a dynamite um uh match-up
and the fact that you you're gonna have
center stage in it too it's just i'm
i'm hyped for you leonard always man i
appreciate you rick
always you know um we've been at it
since college man i appreciate you
always thanks for the call leonard you
be well we'll chat again soon no problem
good luck let's do it down the road
that's leonard fournette
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here